[Musique]
plusieurs blessés dans une attaque à la
voiture bélier cet après midi à
jérusalem est
quelques heures plus tôt ce sont une
quarantaine de palestiniens qui ont été
tués dont de nouvelles frappes
israéliennes sur la bande de gaza
palestiniens et israéliens se renvoient
la responsabilité de cette nouvelle
escalade de violence démarré lundi le
conseil de sécurité devait se réunir en
ce moment-même 20 millions de primo
vaccinées en france ce cap des personnes
ayant reçu une première injection antico
vide a été franchie hier respectant
ainsi l'objectif fixé par le
gouvernement pour la mi-mai des français
qui boudent astrazeneca un million de
doses du sérum tué deux britanniques
restent inutilisés les chiliens élise
les rédacteurs de leur nouvelle
constitution pour un vote historique il
a débuté hier sans grande mobilisation
il se poursuit ce dimanche la nouvelle
constitution remplacera celle rédigée en
1981 sous le régime militaire d'augusto
pinochet
les chiliens espèrent plus de justice
sociale c'était l'une des revendications
issues du soulèvement populaire
d'octobre 2010 9
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france elle visait une
des forces de sécurité israéliennes une
attaque à la voiture bélier a fait de
nombreux blessés cet après midi à
jérusalem est
nouvel épisode des violences qui oppose
israéliens et palestiniens quelques
heures plus tôt des frappes de tsahal
ont tué au moins 42 personnes dans la
bande de gaza ce qui porte à 188 le
nombre de morts dans l'enclavé
palestinienne depuis lundi le hamas n'a
pas bien calculé l'ampleur de notre
réponse déclare aujourd'hui le chef de
l'armée israélienne israël qui en près
d'une semaine a été la cible de quelques
trois mille roquettes lancées par des
groupes armés le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu se penche en ce moment même sur ce
conflit israélo palestinien
à l'ouverture de la réunion virtuelle
antonio gutiérrez sa mise en garde
contre le risque d'une crise régionale
incontrôlable
les affrontements risquent d'entraîner
israéliens et palestiniens dans une
spirale de violence ou conséquences
dévastatrices ont les deux communautés
et pour l'ensemble de la région
il risque de déclencher une crise
sécuritaire et humanitaire incontrôlable
et de favoriser l'extrémisme
non seulement dans les territoires
palestiniens occupés et en israël mais
aussi dans l'ensemble de la région et
chacune des deux parties se renvoient la
responsabilité de la situation à les
palestiniens dénonce une agression
contre leurs peuples et leurs lieux
saints évoque des crimes de guerre quand
israël de son côté accuse le mouvement
islamiste du hamas d'avoir prémédité le
conflit chez coûtait israël assassine
les palestiniens à gaza famille par
famille israël cherche à déraciner les
palestiniens de jérusalem il expulser
les familles une famille à la fois au
logement à la fois à un quartier à la
fois israël persécute notre peuple
il s'est rendu coupable de crimes de
guerre et de crimes contre l'humanité
certains rechignent peut-être à utiliser
ces mots-là crimes de guerre crimes
contre l'humanité mais ils savent bien
que ces mots sont justes ces présidents
ce n'est pas la première fois que le
ramasse cible de façon aveugle en
envoyant des civils en envoyant des
roquettes et des missiles la population
civile israélienne
mais c'est aussi la donne a changé il
ramasse aspirer la destruction de l'état
d'israël et veut prendre le pouvoir en
cisjordanie- remplacer l'autorité
palestinienne et hier l'immeuble qui
abrite al jazeera l agence de presse
américaine ap a été pulvérisé par
l'armée israélienne une cible
parfaitement légitime a réagi
aujourd'hui le premier ministre
israélien benyamin nétanyahou indiquant
que l'immeuble abritait également un
bureau de renseignements pour
l'organisation terroriste palestinienne
qui prépare et organise des attaques
terroristes contre des civils israéliens
fin de citation
retour sur une semaine de très vives
tensions avec grain tout c'est une
semaine rythmée par les violents
affrontements sur terre et dans les airs
des roquettes tirées depuis gaza la
plupart du temps stoppées par le dôme de
fer de tsahal et des bombardements
massifs de l'aviation israéliennes sur
l'enclavé palestinienne
le conflit au proche orient illustré par
ses scènes horrifiante devenue
quotidienne
des édifices entier qui s'écroule en
quelques secondes pulvérisés par les
missiles
le chaos et la désolation accompagne les
ruines toujours plus nombreuses cet
immeuble abritait les locaux de la
chaîne de télévision al jazeera et de l'
agence de presse américaine et hippie
nous sommes choqués et horrifiée par le
fait que l'armée israélienne vise et
détruisent l'immeuble abritant le bureau
des hippies et d'autres médias à gaza ce
que nous faisons notre devoir
professionnel nous n'avons pas
nécessairement à transmettre des
messages
mais le fait de continuer à travailler
et à suivre les événements ainsi que le
fait de continuer à transmettre notre
exercice du journalisme sont considérés
comme une réponse à toutes les parties
qui voudraient peut-être faire taire les
reporters et éteindre des caméras cette
explosion d'un autre bâtiment a été
précédée d'une sommation peu commune une
conversation téléphonique entre le
propriétaire de l'immeuble gazaouis et
un membre de l'armée israélienne la
grosse explosion va arriver dans peu de
temps
elle viendra par l'arrière ou par
l'avant
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas pratique
il ya un espace ville à l'arrière
pourquoi vous endommagez les maisons à
l'avant je vous comprends si dieu veut
seul ce bâtiment sera bombardé côté
israélien plusieurs localités ont été le
théâtre d'affrontements entre chaque
partie impliquée dans le conflit comme
ici dans la ville de lod
les roquettes du hamas ont également
visé certains aéroports de l'état hébreu
dont celui de tel aviv un danger
persistant dans le sial israélien qui a
poussé les compagnies aériennes à
prendre des mesures drastiques et les
prises de parole des autorités de chaque
camp au cours de cette semaine n'ont pas
toujours incité à la désescalade de
barbaira pas je suis ici pour l'une des
batteries du dôme de fer
les commandants les soldats font un
travail extraordinaire pour défendre le
ciel d'israël et les citoyens d'israël
il est impossible d'atteindre 100%
d'efficacité mais il s'en approche de
très près et nous l'apprécions à thuin
sont les activités de défense des
batteries dôme de fer lui donne de
l'espace pour attaquer et l'armée
israélienne a déjà attaqué des centaines
de cible ou dépasseront bientôt le
millier et nous continuerons à frapper
le hamas tout en défendant nos citoyens
cela prendra encore du temps mais avec
une grande détermination à la fois en
défense et en attaque nous atteindrons
notre objectif de rétablir la paix dans
l'état d'israël
s'il s'agit de répondre à votre
agression et de revendiquer la victoire
pour notre peuple et nos valeurs sacrées
il n'y a pas de lignes rouges de règles
d'engagement sacré ou de calculs
compliqués les appels au calme de la
communauté internationale restent pour
le moment ignorés depuis le début des
bombardements
on compte les morts par dizaines dont de
nombreux enfants et les blessés par
centaines
hé les bombardements à gaza pousse de
nombreux habitants à quitter leurs
domiciles force et se réfugie avec leurs
familles notamment dans des écoles
reportage auprès des gazaouis de
mustapha el bayed et yamina benguigui
une nouvelle vague de réfugiés
palestiniens dans les écoles supervisé
par l'office de secours et de travaux
des nations unies pour les réfugiés
palestiniens dans le proche orient
ils fuient les raids aériens israéliens
en particulier dans le nord de la bande
de gaza ce quartier a beaucoup changé
aujourd'hui la plupart des maisons sont
détruites et ses paysages de désolation
sont devenus monnaie courante pour les
palestiniens les stigmates de nombreuses
attaques menées par israël
sajid à al yaziji nous raconte comment
elle a été sortie des décombres avec
douze autres membres de sa famille
[Musique]
mégane et nous on était assis ici on a
été bombardée j'étais là et tous les
membres de ma famille étaient sous les
décombres
j'ai essayé de les sortir mon père était
à l'intérieur
il est sorti pour trouver de l'aide tout
avait explosé j'ai commencé à prier pour
leur âme quand les décombres ont été
dégagés je ne pensais pas que quelqu'un
pourrait encore être en vie
j'étais choquée qu'ils sont encore en
vie leurs maisons détruites ces
personnes n'ont pas d'autre choix que de
se réfugier dans ces écoles ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'ils sont contraintes
de vivre cela nous accompagnons la
famille datar qui quitte le foyer en
attendant la fin de la guerre
cette opération a été menée dans la nuit
contre des civils les raids aveugles
contre des civils n'ont épargné personne
et personne n'a été averti
les enfants criaient nous les avons pris
et nous nous sommes enfuis
nous crions mais personne ne nous entend
ils nous bombardent et nous fuyons de
nos maisons sous les bombardements et
les éclats d'obus
la capacité d'adaptation est une qualité
indispensable pour les habitants de gaza
à l'heure actuelle il considère cette
école comme leurs maisons et des salles
de classe comme un espace de jeux pour
leurs enfants
le peuple palestinien qui reçoit de
nombreux soutiens à travers le monde en
france fière mais aussi en australie au
royaume uni ou encore l'allemagne se
déroulent des manifestations en signe de
solidarité
tour d'horizon en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'exécutif français se fixe comme
nouvel objectif 30 millions de primo
vacciner à la mi juin pierre le seuil
des 10 millions de français qui ont reçu
une première injection antico vide a été
franchie comme attendu par l'exécutif
mais ce n'est visiblement pas
astrazeneca qui est plébiscitée lors de
la vaccination
deux millions de doses du sérum feydeau
britanniques sont inutilisés alors
comment le gouvernement peut-il éviter
le gaspillage
éléments de réponse avec maxime à berre
en france le cap des 20 millions de
primo vacciner a été atteint ce samedi
des chiffres qui selon jean castex
conforte les perspectives de sortie de
crise prochain objectif avancé par le
premier ministre le cap des 30 millions
à la mi juin une épine reste pourtant
plantée dans le pied du gouvernement
le vaccin astrazeneca 2 millions de
doses du vaccin anglo-suédois dorment
encore dans les stocks français sans
trouver preneur
son taux d'utilisation est largement
inférieurs aux concurrents pfizer et
moderne à la faute à une image ternie
par les cas de thrombose et son
efficacité moindre face aux variants
face à cette défiance le gouvernement
tente de trouver des solutions
une des premières pistes avancées la
pédagogie le gouvernement souhaite
s'appuyer sur le personnel de santé pour
améliorer la communication autour du
vaccin et rassurer les patients jean
castex est lui même monté en première
ligne pour défendre le mal aimé je suis
vacciné à l'astra zeneca comme des
dizaines de millions de personnes dans
le monde
ça protège contre les formes les plus
graves de la maladie donc allons-y
d'abord destiné au moins de 65 ans le
vaccin astrazeneca a été élargie aux
seniors avant d'être réservé seulement
aux plus de 55 ans malgré les problèmes
de stocks
le ministre de la santé se montraient
réticents à l'idée d'élargir le vaccin
anglo-suédois au public cible un avis
conforté par la haute autorité de santé
qui conseille de maintenir la limite
d'âge une décharge à signer a été
évoquée mais selon les spécialistes elle
renforcerait la suspicion autour du
vaccin
dernière option envisagée écoulée les
doses à l'étranger si elle veut éviter
le gaspillage la france pourrait être
tenté de donner les doses à ses voisins
c'est ce qu'a fait par exemple le
danemark début avril
en prêtant 55 mille doses à un land
allemand problème nombreux sont les pays
à avoir déjà limité la vaccination avec
astrazeneca autres bénéficiaires
possibles
le programme kovacs emmanuel macron a
annoncé l'envoi de 500 mille doses d'ici
à la mi juin vers les pays les plus
pauvres
reste à savoir quel sera le pourcentage
d'astrazeneca à destination du
dispositif mis en place par le msl jax
astrazeneca ne mérite pas la défiance
des français c'est l'avis de jean paul
stahl infectiologues au chu de grenoble
al
la défiance se vacciner non pas des je
veux dire par là qu'il n'est pas
question de nier les quelques accidents
graves
mais il faut rappeler que ces accidents
de trop roses sont 60
je dis bien 60 points inférieurs aux
risques que courent les jeunes femmes en
prenant la pilule dont il contraceptive
soit 100 fois inférieures et des
personnes ne tire une scène d'alarmé
là-dessus journée ont continué à la
prescrit à titre individuel donc de
cette n'est pas scientifiquement
raisonnable le face aux risques que
représentent plus vite
c'est une absolue évidence le moyennant
quoi la psychologie c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que et sape les annonces
scientifique
le gouvernement fait face à de nombreux
couacs après le débat autour du pass and
i ter première difficulté autour des
autotests dans les lycées en raison de
notices erronée la réouverture des
discothèques elle divise toujours
l'assemblée nationale médiascopie vote
controversé sur le pass and i ter ce
mardi à l'assemblée nationale après
avoir été rejetée en première lecture le
texte a finalement été adopté tard dans
la nuit une mesure polémique qui passe
avec 208 voix contre 85 le modem qui
avait dans un premier temps lâché la
majorité est ensuite rentré dans le rang
en échange d'une réécriture de l'article
clé
le parti centriste allié essentiel des
manuels macron reproche à l air em un
manque de dialogue
on vote sur quoi comme le gouvernement a
des pouvoirs exorbitants ils mettent
ensuite tout ce qu'il veut dans le
décret
le passage au banc de l'assemblée formel
il y à peu d'attention du gouvernement
un autre endroit voire un certain mépris
alors que le sénat doit analyser le
texte sur le pass and i ter le 18 mai
prochain
les français restent divisés sur cette
question et a restreint les libertés de
chacun du coup c'est contraire à la
liberté de conscience la liberté de
choix sachant que la balle c'est un
consentement libre et éclairé même pour
les vaccins ah oui c'est une bonne idée
parce que ça va permettre aux gens qui
hésitaient encore de se vacciner et ça
va ça va obliger les gens à se vacciner
et à résoudre cette situation rapidement
possible je pense que yahia c'est la
seule solution pour voyager pour aller
dans les expositions un peu partout
autre sujet qui a divisé à l'assemblée
dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi la
réouverture des boîtes de nuit le projet
de loi de sortie progressive de l'état
d'urgence ne comporte rien à propos du
sort de ces établissements les acteurs
du secteur n'ont toujours aucune
information sur une éventuelle date de
réouverture
autre couac survenu au cours de la
semaine celui des autotests dans les
lycées 43% des commandes comporte des
notices erronée d'autres sont
accompagnés de mode d'emploi dans
plusieurs langues sauf le français le
ministère de l'éducation nationale s'est
défendu de toute responsabilité et
évoque une erreur du fabricant enfin
toujours en lien avec la crise sanitaire
un rapport remis ce mercredi à jean
castex alerte sur une augmentation de la
pauvreté en france depuis le début de la
pandémie
le conseil national de lutte contre la
pauvreté et l'exclusion sociale
s'inquiète de la situation
la crise a occasionné une aggravation
d'une condition déjà dégradé autant que
l'exposition de nouveaux publics à la
pauvreté
la crise provoque donc un mécanisme
triple qu'il faut garder à l'esprit
d'une part elles entravent les sorties
habituelles de la pauvreté enfin elle
provoque des arrivées inattendu
extrêmement dur dans ses effets au bas
de l'échelle sociale
elle a en revanche épargné le sommet au
milieu de ces couacs et de ses
perspectives peu réjouissantes une note
positive côté vaccination
après un début de campagne marquée par
une certaine lenteur emmanuel macron
annoncé que le cap des 20 millions de
primo vacciner a été atteint ce samedi
et direction le japon confronté à une
recrudescence de l'épidémie
le pays a donc étendu vendredi ce sont
l'état d'urgence a à trois départements
supplémentaires soit 9 concerner au
total dont celui de tokyo
une situation inquiétante à dix semaines
du lancement des jeux olympiques d'été
alors faut-il les maintenir la question
fait débat dans le pays
quentin en clair il n'y aura pas de
médailles à la clé
mais c'est sans doute l'épreuve la plus
importante le japon affronte le coc vite
19 pour une bonne tenue des jeux
olympiques de tokyo réactiver le 7 mai
pour la troisième fois en un peu plus
d'un an l'état d'urgence sanitaire a été
élargi à trois autres districts japonais
cette semaine signe d'une recrudescence
du virus dans le pays
à seulement deux mois et demi du
lancement de l'événement
les doutes sur la tenue des jo prennent
de plus en plus d'ampleur ce samedi le
géant nippon rakuten a pris position sur
ce qu'il estime être une mission suicide
il est dangereux d'accueillir ce grand
événement mondial
le risque est donc trop grand et je suis
contre la tenue des jeux olympiques de
tokyo cette année le recul de la
pandémie n'est pas si important et nous
constatons que de nombreux pays sont
encore en grande difficulté notamment
l'inde et le brésil
et il n'est pas encore temps de faire la
fête au sein de la population japonaise
le maintien des jeux olympiques fait
aussi débat la nouvelle vague de covile
19 qui sévit actuellement au japon fait
grimper le nombre de voix s'opposant à
la tenue de l'événement selon des
sondages 60 à 70 % des japonais seraient
contre le déroulement de la compétition
cet été
une pétition demandant l'annulation djo
de tokyo a même été signée par plus de
350 mille personnes avant d'être remise
à la gouverneur de la capitale nationale
non je pense que les jeux olympiques
relève cette fois ci d'un choix de
priorités entre la vie des gens ou les
cérémonies et l'événement appelé jo nous
y mettons donc entre l'été et l'automne
le cio a le pouvoir de décider d'annuler
ou non l'événement
mais tokyo est aussi la ville haute donc
nous avons fait une demande aux
autorités de tokyo pour qu'elles
encouragent le cio annuler l'événement
les organisateurs de tokyo 2020 ont
annoncé prendre au sérieux cette
pétition
il tente tant bien que mal de rassurer
la population
la présidente de tokyo 2020 estime
qu'avec la mise en place de règles de
stricte les il devrait pouvoir se
dérouler sans encombre en mars nous
avons décidé à contre-coeur que les fans
venons de l'étranger ne pourrait pas
assister aux jeux nous avons également
réviser nos règles d'organisation et
nous avons annoncé des mesures anti
virus très strictes il sera très
important que les gens se tiennent à ces
règles une bulle sanitaire sera mise en
place pour les athlètes et leur
encadrement
les organisateurs espèrent également
pouvoir compter sur la vaccination pour
proposer des jeux olympiques les plus
sécurisants possibles problèmes
la campagne de vaccination tourner au
ralenti au japon seulement un pour cent
de la population a reçu une première
injection
si le gouvernement a annoncé vouloir
vacciner un million de personnes par
semaine pendant la période d'état
d'urgence
la priorité donnée aux athlètes fait
également polémique parmi les japonais
et c'est un vote historique qui se
déroule en ce moment même au chili
depuis hier 14 millions de citoyens sont
appelés à élire les rédacteurs de la
nouvelle constitution constitution
destinée à promouvoir plus de justice
sociale et à tourner la page de l'ère
pinochet
plus de 1300 candidats se sont présentés
155 seront élus les résultats devraient
tomber dont la nuit soul and go dans une
élection sur toutes les lèvres dans ce
marché de santiago du chili
c'est une excellente occasion pour le
pays de réécrire l'histoire et de
laisser aux générations futures
quelque chose de prosper quelque chose
que tout le monde veut c'est bien car
notre constitution est très obsolètes et
avait été créé pour les hommes
d'affaires et les millionnaires pas pour
le peuple
une nouvelle constitution pour tourner
la page de célérité de la dictature
militaire d'augusto pinochet
une des revendications portées par le
plus grand soulèvement social de
l'histoire du chili en octobre 2019
fragiliser le gouvernement du président
sebastian pinera a été contraint
d'accepter un référendum sur le
changement de constitution en novembre
le oui l'a emporté à 80% six mois plus
tard
la population est appelée ce samedi et
ce dimanche à désigner les rédacteurs de
la nouvelle loi fondamentale parmi ses
concitoyens à la veille du rendez vous
la campagne bat son plein dans la
capitale chilienne il faut que cela
reste un état qui n'est pas trop
interventionniste je ne dis pas que le
chili doit cesser d'avoir un système de
santé public pas du tout mais qu'il doit
être meilleur et que l'état ne doit pas
dépenser plus qu'il ne peut parce qu'il
a été définitivement démontré sur ce
continent
que cela signifie la ruine des pays par
conséquent ou deuxième donc également
éliminer les déchets conservateur issu
de la constitution de 1980 qui ont
bloqué bon nombre des réformes que j'ai
voulu promouvoir ces dernières années
comme eux plus de 1300 candidats
indépendants ou appartenant à des partis
politiques de droite comme de gauche
font campagne pour décrocher un siège
parmi les 155 rédacteur de la nouvelle
constitution
la moitié d'entre eux seront des femmes
une première en amérique du sud 17
sièges seront réservés à des
représentants des peuples indigènes et
pour john jay or l alarme créateur du
blog france chili le système mis en
place au chili est enfin s'est créé côté
l'état l'état dans la constitution
actuelle du chili n'existe pas et le on
a vu cette absence de l'état avec la
bande d'amis qui a qui a vraiment fini
par faire éclore le système il était mis
en place le chili était au bout du bout
de d'un cycle il faut qu'ils aient deux
tiers des ses 155 et élus qui vont
rédiger devons avoir la tâche de rédiger
la nouvelle constitution et il faut
avoir un accord des deux tiers pour que
ça puisse avancer et ils n'auront que
douze mois pour au maximum pour rédiger
cette constitution
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain un point sur
l'actu dans une trentaine de minutes à
20 heures à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays africains
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique lors une
vaccination reste une vaccination savez
la vaccination ce n'est pas elle n'a pas
commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même la
provision